[Music]
all right here's a good question and
it's it's related to my disclaimer and
warning earlier linda e robledo i found
myself asking if the subconscious should
always be examined if we are functioning
are we prepared to open pandora's box
with the use of psychedelic treatment
options it seems very scary to me and
not sure why it will repression rear its
ugly head later this is a great question
and commentary
always is a really strong word and i
think it's it's aptly used here right
so
should we always examine the
subconscious if we're functioning
if you are highly functioning
and
things are going well
i it would be hard for me to say that
you should automatically
use psychedelics or that you have to use
psychedelics they are not a panacea
there are risks involved and you can
open up pandora's box and experience
things
that will require processing so if you
don't have space in your life to do that
if you don't have slack in the system to
contend with material that might come up
then
you should consider very carefully
whether or not this is a good time or if
there is any good time for you to use
these compounds
i am not
a
messiah at all i don't view myself as a
hammer looking
for nails with psychedelics they are
contraindicated in many circumstances
they are extremely powerful
people who take them lightly generally
get punished
and you can have long-term consequences
that are very difficult to resolve and
if you're cavalier with some of these
compounds even if they have short
duration in earth time like 5mu dmt in
15 minutes 5 to 15 minutes and people
refer to it as the businessman's high
and the businessman's trip
this is a
dramatic underestimation of just how
destabilizing
and reorienting or disorienting these
compounds can be they're very very
powerful so
i continue to feel that they are
and will be as important as
stan groff has said as important to
psychiatry and the understanding of the
mind as the microscope was to biology
and the telescope was to astronomy i
believe that i completely believe that
both from firsthand experience and from
the research and from anecdotal reports
in great numbers
and right along with that you can
inflict upon yourself
instability or ontological shock that is
incredibly difficult to contend with
so
i don't think that one should always
open up pandora's box with these
compounds
nor do i think that everyone should use
them
even once
and you know for many of these reasons i
also think it's a great
it's a great
state of affairs and a great
place right now with respect to phase
three trials to have mdma assisted
psychotherapy
as the tip of the spear because
mdma
is a compound in the right context with
properly trained therapists that is much
easier to facilitate and to navigate
also to prepare for and to integrate
then classic psychedelics
or novel
newer synthetic psychedelics so i'm very
pleased
that we will hopefully have
time with larger numbers of patients to
refine the systems and
the way
in which these substances are
administered the way that adverse events
are dealt with
with mdma before even soul seven i'm
very very
pleased by that
you